[Música]
el comité de la cámara de representantes
de Estados Unidos Que investigó los
hechos relacionados con el intento de la
toma del Capitolio en ese país recomendó
en su informe final acusar al
expresidente Donald Trump por
obstrucción e insurrección Tenemos
reporte desde la ciudad de Washington
después de días de encuentro sin
negociaciones la Cumbre cop 15 realizada
en Montreal dejó un acuerdo histórico en
materia de biodiversidad que busca
proteger el 30% del territorio del
planeta y de los cuerpos de agua
y buena parte del servicio de
Electricidad y agua ya fue restablecido
en kiev la capital de Ucrania después de
intensos ataques con drones por parte de
las fuerzas armadas rusas que afectaron
seriamente la infraestructura hidráulica
y eléctrica de esa ciudad Europea
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en
Washington en Estados Unidos en donde el
comité de la cámara de representantes de
ese país Que investigó los hechos
ocurridos durante el intento de la toma
el Capitolio el 6 de enero del 2021
presentó sus recomendaciones finales el
comité sugirió que el expresidente
Donald Trump se ha acusado por
obstrucción e insurrección los detalles
en el siguiente reporte de Cristóbal
Vázquez desde la capital de los Estados
Unidos escuchemos el comité que
investigue lo que ocurrió en La Toma del
Capitolio el 6 de enero del 2021 remitió
el ex presidente Donald Trump al
departamento de Justicia por cuatro
delitos primero por obstruir un
procedimiento oficial segundo por
conspirar para defraudar a los Estados
Unidos tercero por conspiración para ser
una declaración falsa y cuarto por
incitar asistir o ayudar o consolar una
insurrección Jimmy ruskin por Maryland
hizo el anuncio oficial al concluir una
investigación que duró 18 meses hay que
Resaltar que esta acción no tiene peso
legal para Donald Trump sin embargo es
la primera vez en la historia que el
congreso hace esta recomendación al
departamento de Justicia que ya adelanta
una investigación independiente por su
cuenta y que podría terminar en más
acusaciones contra el expresidente Trump
el comité también está remitiendo a
cuatro congresistas al comité de ética
por ignorar las recomendaciones del
panel que Investiga lo ocurrido El Seis
de enero Estos son el líder de La
minoría republicana Kevin mccarthy y
posiblemente el próximo presidente del
Congreso y los representantes
de Arizona y seguimos en Estados Unidos
porque elon musk el dueño y ceo de
Twitter realizó una encuesta en la que
le consultó a los usuarios para saber si
continuaba al frente de esta red social
el resultado no favoreció a mosc a la
pregunta si debo renunciar a seguir al
frente de Twitter el 57,5% de los votos
fue a favor de sí de dejar de liderar
esta compañía Mientras que el 42,5% votó
contra la idea de que musk dimita de su
cargo cerca de 17,5 millones de personas
votaron en esta encuesta ahora la
pregunta que queda es sin mosc
continuará o no y si tendrá en cuenta
este sondeo de opinión
en otros temas finalizó la Cumbre de la
cop 15 que tuvo lugar en la ciudad de
Montreal en Canadá el encuentro dejó un
acuerdo histórico en materia de
biodiversidad que tiene como objetivo la
protección del 30% del territorio del
planeta y el mismo porcentaje de los
cuerpos acuáticos hasta el 2030 veamos
el siguiente informe
la Cumbre de la naturaleza de las
Naciones Unidas cerró este lunes con un
acuerdo histórico en Canadá lograron un
compromiso tan relevante como el acuerdo
de París allí sobresale el denominado 30
por 30 el objetivo de proteger el 30% de
la tierra y de las áreas costeras y
marinas al 2030 un buen acuerdo para
todo lo que son las planificaciones
espacial aunque también es cierto que es
insuficiente porque de hecho la ciencia
está pidiendo un 50% de protección del
planeta uno de los puntos de mayor
conflicto estuvo en la financiación los
países más desarrollados aportarán
200.000 millones por año mientras que
las naciones en desarrollo pretendían
mayor cantidad y la creación de un fondo
algo que no sucedió
la financiación generó la disconformidad
de la República democrática de Congo el
segundo país con mayor cantidad de
bosques tropicales del mundo pero las
autoridades chinas no contemplaron el
planteo congolenio como formal y
avanzaron con el acuerdo el cual tan
valió y según representantes africanos
fue aprobado por la fuerza esta
resolución sustituye a los firmados en
Haití en 2010 que nunca se cumplieron
acuerdos muy ambiciosos que no se
cumplieron debido a que no habían
mecanismo de implementación claros los
cuales nadie se hacía responsable porque
no había ninguna manera de ponerlos en
la mesa la cumbre en Montreal apunta a
cumplir una necesidad global evitar una
mayor pérdida de poblaciones de
biodiversidad ya devastadas
nuevamente kiev la capital ucraniana fue
escenario de bombardeos y ataques con
cerca de 35 drones por parte de las
tropas rusas los ataques dejaron Al
menos tres personas heridas y daños
considerables en la infraestructura
eléctrica e hidráulica por lo que fue
necesario realizar algunos cortes en el
suministro de agua y electricidad que
poco después fueron restablecidos
el lunes este pueblo a 40 kilómetros de
quieva amaneció en medio de la
desolación en plena noche la casa de
esta pareja de ancianos fue alcanzada
por un dron su garaje prendió en llamas
el hombre resultó herido
seguía vibrando muy fuerte Entonces se
produjo una explosión muy fuerte y nos
preguntamos Cómo acabaría todo esto para
nosotros
durante toda la noche las sirenas
sonaron en la región de kiev objetivo de
otro asalto aéreo ruso el tercero en
solo seis días una vez más la
infraestructura energética del país fue
blanco como la empresa donde trabaja
esta mujer que escuchó las expresiones
de camino al trabajo
[Música]
Estoy muy ansiosa ansiosa porque nunca
sabes cuándo se acercará a un misil Pero
en cuanto salta la alerta antiaérea
abandonamos inmediatamente la oficina
Gracias
los ataques provocaron nuevos cortes de
agua y electricidad en kiev y 10
regiones del país mientras millones de
ucranianos siguen sumidos en la
oscuridad y el frío desde el pasado
viernes según el presidente Ucrania no
los drones responsables de los asaltos
son de fabricación iraní
anoche 34 drones iraníes sahead
volvieron a atacar Ucrania llegó su
cantidad y su nombre con mucha precisión
son del nuevo lote que Rusia recibió de
Irán
tras este ataque volvió a pedirle a
occidente que proporcione más armas a
Ucrania ya que sus efectivos temen un
posible ataque ruso contra principios de
la falta de alumbrado público ha
permitido un aumento de la delincuencia
de las calles de beirut la capital del
Líbano Esto llevó a que un centenar de
personas creara una vigilancia vecinal
para protegerse ante las limitaciones de
las fuerzas de seguridad con palos y
también con linternas patrullan las
calles de la ciudad entre ellas las del
barrio cristiano veamos
no son más de las seis de la tarde pero
la sensación es de media noche recibe
una llamada y organiza el resto del
grupo para salir a patrullar por asfire
la falta de alumbrado público en las
calles ha hecho aumentar la delincuencia
en este barrio cristiano de virú Has
visto cómo estás rafiche completamente
oscuras es un derecho básico que
nuestros vecinos nuestros hijos se
sientan seguros cuando salgan o regresen
a sus casas por eso estamos aquí un
total de 120 voluntarios entrenados por
una compañía de seguridad participan en
esta iniciativa de vigilancia vecinal
para proteger al barrio mariama ha
tenido que adelantar la hora de cierre
de la tienda porque no se siente segura
con la calle oscura
antes se roba las siete pero ahora no
hay luz en la calle y no vienen clientes
está de cierta me da miedo no hay
seguridad
en un país como Líbano marcado
profundamente por el sectarismo el hecho
de que un grupo de vigilantes nocturnos
reclutado por un importante partido
cristiano haya decidido actuar por su
cuenta ha creado controversias para
Michelle sabarí que vivió la guerra
civil y apoyo acabando cristiano esta
iniciativa de vigilancia vecinal es un
regreso al pasado
es un tiempo complicado estamos sin
presidente ni gobierno todo el mundo
está pidiendo que se desmantele la
milicia que esbolá es peligroso tener
ahora otro grupo encargándose de la
seguridad en su zona
pero el diputado navideño fundador de
2020 rechaza que su iniciativa comparte
similitudes con las patrullas durante la
Guerra Civil de Vanesa
no estamos en una guerra civil todo lo
contrario no estamos para reemplazar a
las fuerzas de seguridad trabajamos en
completa coordinación con la policía y
las agencias de seguridad internacional
Más allá de la polémica mientras el
barrio las vacías sigue a oscuras estos
vigilantes nocturnos continuarán
resguardando su comunidad ante las
limitaciones de las fuerzas policiales
para dar seguridad
esto en las noticias siga con nosotros
[Música]